[Music]
what i want to tell you is that you know
that is this lady zara
i was with her before
and then i started taking two like
two weeks then i started talking to that
lady
but if you can remember when i started
talking to it wasn't a relationship it
wasn't any feeling so what are you
saying right now what are you trying to
tell me i'm just telling you for you to
me because i don't want to why are you
telling me this now like why ruin my day
i'm not ruining it i'm just being honest
is there anything wrong for me telling
you the secret that you do there's
something to tell me yeah i tell you
everything
how dare you keep a secret for me
seriously
because then we are not in relationship
it doesn't matter why didn't you tell
them no it does and i've been loyal this
whole time are you kidding me that's why
i'm telling you
i know in a relationship i need to tell
you now because if you know it now
you're telling me now but i've been
loyal this whole time you're making me
look like a fool yo
when i bought the ep and i asked you
zara was you did not tell me zara was
somebody you were dating you told me
zara was just a name you picked out for
all the women across the world but i
never knew that you were dating this
girl back then i was in relationship
with zara but
she broke up with me
i was hurt honestly because i truly
loved that girl
when did you end it with her about four
months now so like what are you saying
wow four months ago that's when i
released we've been talking for a year
that's crazy as hell because i thought
i was the one that was like repairing
his heart okay and his trust but during
this time that i was putting this work
in he's dating a whole nother chick
oh the best
i feel stupid i feel stupid i even came
down here
that's how i feel